et c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus à la une ce soir
l'urgence climatique au coeur de la
cop15 le coup d'envoi a été lancé par
alassane ouattara ce lundi à abidjan en
présence d'une douzaine de chefs d'état
dont 9 du continent objectif mettre
rapidement en place des mesures pour
lutter contre la sécheresse et la
désertification
la course contre la montre au burkina
faso pour retrouver les huit mineurs
sont bloqués depuis le 16 avril à
plusieurs centaines de mètres sous terre
nous ferons le point sur les opérations
en cours dans ce journal et il continue
de suivre la cuvette et tchadienne de
près depuis l'allemagne où il s'est
exilé le journaliste et écrivain eric
toppan amorena et l'invité à mon invité
ce soir auteur de l'essai pour la
refondation du tchad pour reviendrons
bien sûr sur sa vision pour l'avenir de
son pays
agir vite contre la désertification le
mot d'ordre est lancé la cop15 a débuté
ce lundi abidjan présence d'alassane
ouattara la côte d'ivoire entend être à
la pointe de la lutte contre la
sécheresse plusieurs régions du
continent sont déjà fortement impactées
par la hausse des températures et la
désertification comme nous l'expliquent
notre correspondante à abidjan annan
ferdjani
4 millions d'hectares de forêts
disparaissent chaque année est de plus
en plus de terres arables perdre dans
fertilité sur le continent africain un
phénomène souvent synonyme de pauvreté
de précarité alimentaire mais aussi de
déplacement de masse et de conflit selon
l'organisation des nations unies
aujourd'hui ce sont les présidents des
pays participants à la conférence qui se
sont réunis et ont discuté des enjeux de
la lutte contre la désertification selon
le président du comité d'organisation
l'engagement démontré lors de cette
conférence des chefs d'état et sans
précédent que nous sommes dans une
situation aujourd'hui où tous les
clignotants sont au vert tant au niveau
politique tant au niveau financier il
est temps maintenant de passer à
l'action et de restaurer et réhabiliter
ses dizaines de millions d'hectares qui
sont dégradées passer à l'action c'est
justement le plaidoyer de nombreux
représentants de la société civile et
des ong emmanuel seck
environnementalistes se félicite qu
autant d'attention soit aujourd'hui
portée à la lutte contre la
désertification
mais selon lui les changements ne
peuvent plus attendre après tant
d'années donc depuis 92 on parle de la
convention de lutte contre la
désertification
la convention sur les changements
climatiques et on se pose toujours des
questions en ce qui concerne les
financements donc de tous ces programmes
là et les populations attendent à ce qu
on puisse de façon beaucoup plus
efficiente prendre en charge tous ces
problématiques qui se posent à eux de
façon disons fréquentes et intenses la
question de l'autosuffisance alimentaire
occupera une grande partie des débats au
moment où la dépendance des pays
africains notamment de vis-à-vis du blé
russe et ukrainien fait craindre une
crise alimentaire sans précédent
la cop15 s'achèvera le 20 mai prochain
au burkina faso les opérations
d'excavation se poursuivent les équipes
de secours sont sur le point d'atteindre
les huit mineurs bloqués depuis le 16
avril dernier en espérant qu'ils aient
pu trouver refuge dans un des tunnels de
la mine le récit de laurent berkshire
bloqués depuis 23 jours le sort des huit
mineurs pris au piège dans la mine de
perkoa n'est toujours pas scellé arrivé
à 580 mètres sous terre les secouristes
doivent maintenant pomper l'eau et
creusé à l'horizontale pour atteindre
une chambre refuge équipés de kits de
survie où il espère retrouver les
ouvriers une course contre la montre
mais les autorités continuent d'y croire
si la chose avance quand nous l'avons
chouette au niveau de la mine et que
nous le constations je pense que il ya
beaucoup d'espoir à voir donc on atteint
rapidement
des lissiers chaque jour familles et
proches se réunissent au poste de crise
de réaux pour suivre l'évolution du
sauvetage tous dénoncent la lenteur de
l'entreprise canadienne responsable de
l'exploitation de la mine qui aurait
d'abord ignoré leurs appels à l'aide
jusqu'à ce que le gouvernement fasse
pression pour trouver une solution à la
crise
les choses commencent à bouger
si le gouvernement avait fait pression
depuis le début nous ne serons pas ici
aujourd'hui
les huit mineurs se sont retrouvés pris
au piège par la montée des eaux le 16
avril dernier il aura fallu attendre
cinq jours avant le début des opérations
de sauvetage et on en vient ce nouveau
massacre en ituri dans l'est de la
république démocratique du congo au
moins 35 personnes ont été tuées
dimanche matin dans l'attaqué d'une mine
d'or artisanale l'écho dès qu une milice
qui prétend défendre les membres de la
communauté lendou sont pointés du doigt
et précision de notre correspondant
clément bonnes roues
l'attaqué a été menée à l'aube et a duré
plusieurs heures à proximité d'une mine
d'or artisanale dans le territoire de
djugu à plus de 100 km de la capitale
provinciale bunia selon la société
civile les victimes sont en majorité des
creuseurs et des membres de leur famille
et c'est d'ailleurs leur campement qui a
été visée il se situe dans la forêt à
plusieurs kilomètres de la position
militaire la plus proche on parle pour
l'instant d'un bilan provisoire de
plusieurs dizaines de morts dont un bébé
de quatre mois mais des dizaines de
personnes ont également fui ou ont été
kidnappés et les recherches se
poursuivaient encore ce lundi pour les
retrouver la société civile et les
autorités pointent du doigt les
miliciens de la codeco la coopérative
pour le développement du congo il s'agit
d'un groupe essentiellement composé de
membres de la communauté lendou qui
multiplie depuis 2019 les attaques
contre la communauté emma et les forces
de sécurité selon l'armée cette milice
se disputaient le contrôle de la mine
d'or avec la milice zaïre il s'agit d'un
groupe d'autodéfense composé en majorité
de membres de la communauté emma les
attaques des codeco ont fait au moins
550 morts ces six derniers mois on a
appris le décès de jodie lukoki
l'international congolais s'est éteint
aux pays-bas ce lundi à l'âge de 29 ans
l'information a été confirmée par son
dernier club le fc twente et les
circonstances de sa mort n'ont pas été
communiqués il a été sélectionné à trois
reprises en amical avec la république
démocratique du congo né à kindu est
arrivé très jeune aux pays bas il à l
ailier a fait ses classes au prestigieux
centre de formation de l'ajax amsterdam
en toutefois parvenir à s'imposer
et toujours aucune fumée blanche ne se
dégage depuis doha au qatar la capitale
accueille depuis près de deux mois
maintenant les délégations tchadienne
participants prêts au dialogue national
des pourparlers qui n'ont toujours pas
abouti la situation politique est dans
l'impasse d'autant que le dialogue
national inclusif devait débuter ce
mardi 10 mai et il a été reporté sine
die et pour évoquer cette crise
politique je reçois eric topo namanga
bonsoir jour soit vous êtes journaliste
en charge de l'actualité africaine pour
la deutsch vélo en allemagne je ma
première question le pré dialogue se
tient depuis le 13 mars à doha il faut
parvenir à trouver un terrain d'entente
entre une soixantaine de délégations les
représenter aussi le représentant du
gouvernement de transition rien ne
semble filtrer est ce que cette mission
elle n'était pas trop ambitieuse moi je
pense que c'était prévisible un vu que
déjà le nombre pléthorique des boucles
et belle qu'on appelle les
politico-militaires 50 de sa pizza j'ai
déjà une issue calamiteuse et le
gouvernement tchadien ou s'il n'avait
pas un agenda assez clair parce qu'il y
avait il ya des sujets de fond que
jamais n'a ne souhaitait pas voir
figurer dans le projet d'accord et donc
ça piétine et je pense que beaucoup de
tchadiens attendent que la fumée blanche
puisse apparaître ou que le grand
dialogue national n'djamena puce
également eu lieu mais ce que les
tchadiens pense que dans tout cas ce
qu'ils gardent espoir que ces divisions
vont pouvoir être dépassé je pense qu'on
n'a pas tous les partis plus menteur ont
intérêt à ce qu'un accord soit trouvé et
le gouvernement tchadien qui comme je le
disais un agenda caché et les groupes et
belle qui pour la plupart ne
représentent que leurs propres hommes
donc je pense que pour l'avenir
sein du tchad il faudrait que les deux
parties arrivent à s'entendre pour que
le crépitement des armes puissent cissé
lô qu'enfin le grand dialogue national à
djamena puisse avoir lieu afin que une
vie démocratique normale puisse avoir
lieu au tchad alors vous avez baigné
très tôt dans la politique puisque votre
père et célestin tottenham manga il est
le vice président de l'ue ndlr de
l'opposant saleh kebzabo saleh kebzabo
d'ailleurs quitte à doha votre père a
été nommé conseiller chargé de mission
du président de la transition pour le
compte de l'une des aires pourquoi le dr
longtemps dans l'opposition a décidé
d'assouplir sa position politique
d'abord je ne suis pas le porte parole
de l'une des aires moi je suis
journaliste c'est ce genre d' amalgame
qui m'a conduit en prison en 2013 parce
que les jambes lit toujours les
activités politiques de paris demandent
la question à la fin de vie du
journaliste bon le journaliste moi je
pense que le r n'est pas le seul parti
politique de l'opposition qui a accepté
d'entrer dans le processus de transition
et à d'autres formations politiques je
pense qu'ils ont certainement dû se dire
bon c'est une nouvelle qui est en train
de s'ouvrir à plus d' essai du puissant
un débit il fallait donc s'associe à la
transition pour espérer apporter chacun
sa modeste pierre aucun chat d'un
nouveau intégrée fondée puisse être
effectif alors vous avez dû quitter
votre pays il y a huit ans maintenant
vous étiez journaliste alors à la radio
nationale tchadienne vous avez été
condamné à trois ans de prison avec
sursis pour complot et atteinte à
l'ordre constitutionnel pour des faits
que vous avez toujours nier avec les
changements politiques qui s'annonce
peut-être est-ce que vous envisagez
désormais un retour au tchad je lai que
je dis à tous ceux qui me pose la même
question le tchad il est dans mon coeur
ranger le porte dans mon coeur j'ai
quitté canton mon gré
mon pays maintenant avec ce changement
ou ces changements en vue
je sens temps d'observer parce que le
dialogue piétine
je pense que mama débit à un agenda
caché puisque le régime de son père est
resté intact c'est un seul élément du
système qui est partie du débit le même
système est en place donc j'attends de
voir d'abord l'évolution du processus de
dialogue et j'aviserai
alors vous venez publier ce livre
intitulé essais pour la refondation du
tchad le tchad qui vous tient à coeur et
vous développez plusieurs chantiers
construire l'état de droit miser sur la
jeunesse sanctuariser les libertés ou
encore diversifier l'économie pourquoi
avoir écrit un tel essai c'était aussi
ma modeste contribution enfin l'idée du
cuir se tait c'est même est venu juste
au lendemain du décès du président déby
je me suis dit ah tiens c'est peut-être
l'occasion de mettre sur papier mes
idées pour que le chat puisse être
laufon 10 et surtout la question de
l'armée nationale qui me tient à coeur
et les clanique quand vous savez l'armée
est composé exclusivement parce que pas
de 100 % des membres de la communauté
sarawak et l'ethnie du président deby et
ça je les écris dans l'essai il faudrait
vraiment que l'armée tchadienne plus est
une américaine ils viendront ensuite les
autres chantiers l'éducation qui doit
être repensée la justice l'injustice
l'impunité
on a beaucoup beaucoup de chantiers et
il va falloir que les autorités de la
transition sera créé afin qu'ils soient
de bonne foi au cours de ce dialogue
national que l'état vient puces se dire
les quatre vérités qu'on puisse tourner
toute cette page cette série de pages
sombres de l'histoire politique de notre
pays parce que vous êtes sans savoir que
depuis
1960 et l'accession du cha de
l'indépendance le pays n'a fait que
vivre une série de crises
sociopolitiques de guerre civile la
surfant
communautarisme là il faudrait que tout
ça s'arrête et enfin qu'on puisse avoir
cette saison il va falloir que mamad
débit offre cette chance aux tchadiens
et peut aussi s'offrir une chance à
lui-même de rentrer dans l'histoire en
offrant un chat de plus sûrs à ses
compatriotes et je pense que l'histoire
avec intérêt son nom s'il le fait ainsi
et quelle est selon vous la plus grande
difficulté que doit surmonter le chat
justement pour parvenir à casser ces
clivages il faut des élections libres et
transparentes
parce que des plus que 10 des bills de
faim a été à la tête du pays on n'a
jamais organiser de bonnes élections il
faudrait qu'à l'issue de ce dialogue
national on puisse organiser de très
bonnes élections que les tchadiens
puisse désigner à la transparence le ou
la personne qui va donc présider à ses
destinées et le nouvel élu ou la lgv est
le lui mettra maintenant me vois tous
ces chantiers que je décris dans mon
livre est temps que le pouvoir
chaudière au bout du fusil et ce qui est
le cas actuellement je pense que le pays
ne va jamais renouer avec les cycles de
vie politique normale vous voyez des
signaux de changement de la part du
gouvernement de transition du conseil
national de transition il faut être
honnête il ya eu quand même les actes
forts qui opposait depuis l'arrivée et
donc au pouvoir demain matin 10 deby
itno les manifestations commencé par
être autorisé certains formations
politiques qui étaient interdites alors
pendant le rein de son père ont obtenu
une autorisation de fonctionner on sent
que la parole commence par être libéré
s'il ya des signes encourageants
beaucoup d'exilés sont rentrés le
gouvernement de transition est en train
de se battre pour organiser un dialogue
national mais ce n'est pas suffisant je
pense que je vais rester prudent et très
lucide parce que rien n'indique que matt
idriss déby ne voudra pas s'éterniser au
pouvoir le pouvoir il est clanique son
père l'a invité à l'issue d'une
rébellion je ne sais pas si les membres
de la communauté vont accepter que mam
at il dit ce débit organise de bonne
direction et que si le ps le parti de
son père ne paye pas est-ce que ce
pouvoir qui est
communautariser acceptera
cet état de fait c'est à voir eric
toppan armand makonda ma dernière
question très rapidement en lisant votre
livre on a l'impression que c'est
presque un programme électoral est-ce
que vous ambitionnez de changer de voie
il peut être est ce que vous en ayez un
engagement politique je suis tchadien je
pense que j'ai le droit d'avoir des
ambitions politiques mais pour l'heure
je d'auberge journaliste je suis fier du
travail que j'ai fait au niveau de la
dot cheveux mais peut-être l'avenir nous
le dira le pauvre leur apporte donc je
n'ai pas fermé voilà la porte n'est pas
fermée a fortement au desk contribution
pour que mon pays puisse changer du
cycle qu'on ait une vie démocratique
paisible comme un centre de pays merci
beaucoup eric toppan à magna je rappelle
que vous êtes journaliste en charge de
l'actualité africaine pour la dot chevet
le en allemagne et c'est la fin du
journal de l'afrique se retrouve dans
moins d'une heure pour une nouvelle
édition à tout à l'heure
[Musique]